when you see Best Cinematography on your
Oscar ballot what does that entail have
you even decide what a good
cinematographer is well we brought
together three expert cinematographers
to talk about their craft and give us
some insight so what is cinematography
what is it entail when you when you show
up on the set and when you're preparing
for a film especially what are you
worried about what are you thinking
about well i think you you're telling
the story visually and you have to
collaborate with 41 the director on
making sure that you're telling the
story of that film and not just going
and doing pretty pictures also
collaborating with the other departments
to create a look of the movie that is
consistent with what the story of the
film is our most important thing to take
care of his the atmosphere of the film
the story is there the director has a
vision and then you come in it is the
atmosphere and and the the mood what we
have to create is a new world a new
world that is based on the story of the
script and we do that through lights to
camera angle where we choose to put the
camera if it is I level but all these
cameras are or we go and go low and
shoot up Google hires you down all these
different angles together created other
key dimensionality and then when you
have a ballot in front of you and you
have five movies to choose from what
what do you guys look for and to make
those judgments I think consistency one
if within the film within the film if it
doesn't mean every shot looks the same
but consistent in the creative form
because if the movie isn't consistent it
means visually it means it's throwing
you out of accepting that story the
second is is the decision as far as the
visual style as I watched a movie if I
can't if I feel like I don't want to
blink or take my eye off the screen then
there's something about the
cinematography that's pulling me into
that in concert with the story that's
where I start to now pick which films I
think are the ones I want to nominate
this year which I totally great down and
I now's the
also thinking that once I if I'm
watching a film and I'm taking away from
that emotional journey of those
characters then and I'm noticing the
cinematography and it seems to be
telling the wrong story then I then I
think that that's a bad thing how do you
differentiate between different sort of
genres or styles of film in the context
of voting for the Oscar I can example
the tree of life and you go these are
only the opposite films there are both
masterpieces in the sense of consistency
in their world in a completely different
way am I going to invest my emotion you
go yes in completely different note it
do I do it into your flat yes and then
hold all the way so they're both
obviously great sometimes but then how
do you decide which one you think is
deserving to win in this case I wouldn't
I couldn't very simple well okay because
they both as good as well as the author
so then you'll drop as a coin is it if
you if you really cannot find is it is
it almost it then it does it come down
to sort of a matter of personal taste
then it's always a person p yeah i think
so subjective yeah but i don't think
that you should choose a category like
cinematography on whether you like the
movie or not so what what how do you
sort of differentiate between all of
these different if there's a couple of
films that I think that are very close
i'll go and watch them again at the
cinema and and with what we're talking
about for all the areas and the
consistency of the sim tog raphy the
style that works for the drama the
moment tells it sets up the right
atmosphere for the characters and the
emotional journey that it takes you
through and i just have to work out
which one to me does does the best job
alright well thank you all for taking
the time out to talk with us and now
that you know a little bit more about
cinematography go to oscar calm and fill
out your my pics game ballot and then
share your predictions with your friends